my last question on let's say the
sovereign wealth funds is could you see
them getting into mining at some point
yeah great question and yes that is my
plan and here's that goes to the ist
issue okay here's the solution all right
let's say you can't get a rent your
compliance department can't get around
the issue
of esg because it's still out there and
they're still have compliance uh and and
ethics committees and these big funds
and so here's a solution let's say you
go from scratch let's say you go to west
texas and you want to build a gig
facility and build it out in 250
increments and you and you basically
guarantee the investors that you're only
going to use wind and solar and you
agree to the texas grid that you'll pay
back
some of your production
and you go to the capital markets and
say
every time we're awarded a coin it stays
on the balance sheet of this investment
so you know a certainty that your coin
was mined in this facility that you
won't
that's what i'm doing and that's a big
solution for me because i i get to check
the box now
on esg for anybody that's even saying to
me where does your coin come from i
can't do that if i buy an etf i can't do
that if i just go and buy a coin in the
open market but i can do that if i was
awarded the coin in an esg compliant
facility and there's enough point to be
mined left that you're going to see a
lot of capital but to work and not just
the geography in west texas there's
other jurisdictions in northern europe
that are looking at this proposal as
well so you're basically going into the
government office saying we are going to
mine sustainably we're going to do it
give us the permits give us access to
the grids give us all the things we need
to be able to service this facility and
let us get to work so i've got bill from
abra here what's your take on the esg
stuff
well uh kevin really great to meet you
very impressed with how deep you've gone
on this topic uh it's not easy so
much respect there
um i guess
you know two questions right first i
understand that the esg issue hasn't
quoted gone away
but
one do the numbers really support the
narrative when you go deep that the
issue
should exist
and do you actually think that you could
produce enough energy in wind and solar
at large scale to make a dent
uh in the hash power war assuming that
we get back to the current
uh hash power numbers by this time next
year actually i'm assuming we would be
ahead of the the
pre-china crackdown numbers by this time
next year and would wind in solar
actually make enough of a dent to even
warrant the investment
it's a great question you can't do it
with solar alone it's a combination of
wind and solar which makes it expensive
but it's definitely it is g compliant
and let me tell you
i agree with you around the debate i
mean if you want to own bitcoin own
bitcoin but it's not that simple if you
have a compliance department and you
have the larry fake letter hanging over
everybody knows about the larry think
letter in fact everybody also knows that
blackrock has hired a chief esg
officer and so if you are being serviced
by and every sovereign fund in the world
works with blackrock pretty well
you really can't go against that mandate
it's not going to work for you you've
got to solve it and so the question is
you got to check the box on esg or you
can't play in the coin space if you're
tied into those metrics so it's not like
they don't want to
it's they can't it's the same issue
about you know buying certain goods and
services from banned countries um that's
what the ethics committee stopped you
there too i i really i really work in
this in this in this institutional world
and
it's not like you can call up the chief
compliance officer and have a dialogue
regarding the merits of mining bitcoin
with existing energy sources
they just don't give a [ __ ] they're not
going to take the call they're just
saying no so when they see how much
money is being made in the space don't
you think they're just going to change
the narrative to fit what they need it
to be to make the investment which is
what i mean come on they do that anyway
i mean and also they're not eliminating
all the companies from the fortune 500
that probably wouldn't pass muster on
the same usage around esg
uh if they weren't already in the
portfolio today
well that's not true actually if you
look at the allocations even calpers
alone said this after the faint letter
they're going to downsize their energy
holdings
but probably we're up at 20 percent they
may be down as low as eight now and you
can see it reflected in large energy
energy names like uh you know
schlumberger and exxon and mobile
they're they're they're getting their
pes compressed because the incremental
buyer is not there anymore
on the highway on the hydrocarbon
mandate coming out of the white house so
there's some pretty big uh forces at
play and when you talk about you know if
you'd only own bitcoin at 8 000. now
it's over 60 000 to a to a sovereign
fund that's running
you know 30 40 50 60 billion dollars
it's a rounding error
they don't care and
and it's the same time it's the greatest
opportunity for those of us that have
invested in cryptocurrencies is to solve
this problem for them
i mean
it's not going to get solved
debating it with the compliance officer
it's going to get solved when they can
simply check the box saying this
facility in norway this facility in
northern quebec this facility in
northern alberta and this facility in
west texas where the places i'm looking
at
mine sustainably as
agreed to with the government the
government has certified this est
compliant facility
then then the debate's over in fact
those are the very people that i'm going
to to raise capital from to build out
these facilities because it solves their
problem the same compliance office that
won't let the fund buy bitcoin will put
money in the ground to build a facility
to to to minecoin if it's csg compliant
go fair
yeah